and his love for her it changes her life
last night Lady Gaga was seen kissing
Christian Kirino whom she just publicly
referred to as her fiance for the first
time the overwhelming joy and excitement
the 32 year old superstar and her 49
year old agent were out in Beverly Hills
where she proudly displayed her pink
diamond she's worn the rock on that
finger since last November without
explaining its significance today Gaga's
rep confirmed the good news and a source
tells et they've been engaged since late
last year it's nice to you know be
having success together mother monster
was of course engaged before back in
2015 to boyfriend of five years Taylor
Kenny they broke it off in 2016 but
remain amicable he even just praised her
performance in a star's beat but I'll
tell you that I'm really proud it's
watching someone live their dream so
continued success and I hope it I hope
it keeps climbing we first saw Christian
and Gaga together at 2017 Super Bowl
they've remained strategically low-key
not posing on any red carpet our source
says they kept the engagement private so
it wasn't the media storm it was with
Taylor you'll remember he was frequently
on Gaga's on I am
absolutely so happy and deeply in love
as for her new man he's a dad to two
girls which would make Gaga a stepmom
she always wanted children I want kids I
want a soccer team a soccer team meaning
many kids yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]